nice right now
we're ahead of schedule that's great we
are four minutes I can't believe
somebody want to see like stream yeah
let me just give a bit of an advanced
warning in some sense this is perhaps
more of a theory talk than you've heard
in other talks during this workshop but
that's because I think this is a bit
more at say the early stages and I hope
that didn't say a couple years one or
two years either myself or someone else
and these audience will be able to give
a more applied talk based on some of the
things here in this talk and I will say
that like while it is the theory talk
some of the concerns which will really
highlight at the beginning of the talk a
really thing that do come up in
practical data analysis which a lot of
people this week have mentioned so yeah
with that preamble I'm going to tell you
about privately learning high
dimensional distributions this is a
joint work with my friends and
collaborators Jerry Lee Vikram Singh
Howe and John almond and I'll mention
that some of the slides in this talk
were kind of modified from versions of
John as you will see he's a much better
artist than I will be able to based on
some of the pictures so let's start with
the setup of this problem I'm going to
first make a distinction between
algorithms versus statistics and so an
algorithm is typically you know we have
some sort of data set which is fed into
some algorithm and we get some sort of
utility the quality of the solution is
measured in terms of some function of
the output Y as compared to the input
data set X but today I'm going to be
talking more about statistical tasks
which have seemingly a rather similar
set up but actually there's going to be
a distribution P which generates the
data set X and note that here I've
chained the definition of what utility
will mean to be in terms of the output Y
with respect
to the distribution P rather than the
input data set X so the picture we have
here then this is the general type of
setup and our goals will be roughly as
follows
there's going to be two digit errata the
first thing we want is true like the the
statistical accuracy type guarantee even
ignoring privacy the sort of the core
thing we would want we want our
algorithm to be accurate and this is
sort of a stochastic guarantee with high
probability over the data set generated
from the distribution this may require
assumptions about the distribution which
generates the data to hold for example
that it might have be Gaussian or have
bounded moments of some sort and today
the goal will be to estimate the
distribution P I'll in a few slides talk
a bit more about what I mean by that and
the second thing of course this is a
privacy workshop so we're going to want
the algorithm to be private
the one thing I'm going to highlight is
that we want our algorithm to always be
private on any sort of realization of
this data set X we're going to want
privacy so let me just sort of emphasize
again this is like we always want
privacy but the accuracy sort stochastic
assuming good things happen when we
generate our data set and today I'm
going to focus on results mentioning
which are in the model of epsilon
squared concentrate differential privacy
but don't worry too much about the
specific definition everything I'm going
to talk about today is sort of like for
any sort of approximate differential
privacy there's I think some very
interesting open questions about pure
differential privacy in these models
which I'm not going to delve too much
into yeah and the general type of
question we're gonna ask is what is the
additional cost to guarantee one and two
as opposed to just guaranteeing one
before we move on are there any
questions about the general setup you
might mention that in the next type but
cost measured as in
yeah in terms of the amount of data you
need to get an accurate estimate or sort
of equivalently what sort of rates you
will get as a function of the various
number of samples per privacy parameter
etc and possibly other parameters which
will come out very soon
good so I promised I'll start by making
a giving a concrete example of where one
of the core problems could come up in
data analysis so imagine we're given a
set of female heights x1 through xn
compute the average height I'm focusing
on female heights just because this
should be roughly Gaussian whereas male
and female heights may be a mixture of
gaussians and also because today the
International Women's Day so so the data
set might look something like this
neither Heights and centimeters and so
perhaps more mathematically the question
you would want to answer is given a set
of samples X I which are iid compute the
expectation of the distribution which
generated them okay so like let me ask
you if you want to privately estimate
the mean tell me your first answer how
would you do this quick don't think
about too much caffeine mechanism
Laplace mechanism for the purposes of
this example I'm going to say the
Laplace mechanism so we all know that
the Laplace mechanism would do something
of I guess we need a normalization
factor here which I did but the idea is
we would take the empirical mean and
then add Laplace noise the issue of
course with just as a state of this is
what exactly is this Delta what is the
sensitivity it's a statistic and if
you're naive then you could have Delta
equals real max in the sense that all
you know about if you all you know about
your data set is that it's going to be
somewhere between zero and you know
infinity the best you can sort of what
you'll do is you'll have to add noise
which is proportional to 1.8 times 10 to
the 308 which I'm sure you'll see you
gives you know sort of accuracy
guarantees so this didn't seem like the
best thing but can we can we do
something anything better than this
well one thing you can do instead is use
some sort of a priori knowledge you
might have about the data in the sense
that suppose I hadn't looked at the data
at all I kind of have a general belief
that most females will be between 120
centimeters and 200 centimeters between
say 4 feet and 7 feet roughly so I can
maybe use this sort of information in
order to limit the sensitivity of my
statistic in particular now I want to
put these vertical bars here which are
kind of a say clamping or clipping or
winds arising I guess is a statistical
term for this at 120 and 200 and I kind
of expect my data to live in here and
this will dust limit the sensitivity of
the statistic however it's now 80 which
is much much better than 10 times 3 to
the 308 or whatever but the thing is 80
over epsilon is still a fairly large
amount of noise right there's something
perhaps you'd like to minimize the cost
based on this type of uncertainty even
worse I claim that things will get worse
in sort of high dimensional settings for
example this was sort of a univariate
problem if you wanted to do a similar
type of clipping and higher dimensions
maybe you know you'd have an estimate
for each dimension independently but the
thing is this would compose over
dimensions and in fact you would get
something which is say dependent on the
dimension a square root D fact or even
in terms of how bad your bound is so
either this is a challenge which will
become especially pronounced in high
dimensional estimation problems and our
overall goal will be to try to minimize
the cost due to this uncertainty in our
parameter estimates so this is kind of
like our sort of end goal here we're
gonna try to get algorithms which have
low cost of because of this our
uncertainty or a continue are there any
questions about this sort of phenomenon
yes I mean the probability that our
bounds don't aren't justified like the
probability of females with Heights that
are different yeah yeah with the idea
that we're gonna want to have some like
reasonable belief about where the actual
data should lie in setting this up in
the fleet will you adjust you idea about
where the data lies based on yeah
essentially the idea is though the way
the algorithms will work eventually
skipping ahead a bit we're going to sort
of start with a very coarse estimate and
it'll be possible in some ways to refine
the estimate based on statistics of the
data yeah for example like imagine you
clipped it at this and then you
estimated the mean based on a lot of
noise maybe you would see that oh
actually you know perhaps their data
actually lives in this interval and then
we can iteratively reduce it so this is
the idea I sort of ideally would
privately add noise proportional to
where the data lies but we don't know
that so we try to privately estimate an
iterate that's a good question
we're going to we're going to use to do
it in terms of total variation distance
overall but it can essentially be if you
want to estimate the mean of a
distribution you're going to want it to
be something like proportional to Sigma
over 6 square root and kind of the
accuracy guarantee we want hey that's
the non-private rate at least cool so
this is just a there's a univariate
problem and in fact there's been a good
amount of work into univariate problems
in the sense let me just give you an
example of the type of theorem you're
gonna see in this talk I'm going this is
just the sort of simplest of private
algorithm in fact this sort of a
uncertainty problem does not even come
up in this problem and that's suppose we
wanted to estimate the mean of a
Bernoulli distribution up to plus or
minus alpha then there exists a private
algorithm which does this with a 1 over
alpha squared plus 1 over alpha epsilon
samples this will give us something
which is biased up to plus minus out
alpha
and if you prefer rate this might be a
term you're more used to but I want to
compare this with the private cost which
is one over alpha squared so you can see
this one over Alpha Epsilon is the kind
of additional cost due to privacy so the
most basic thing but also more
interesting settings have been studied
I say reasonably well understood I say
this in a theory sense the first thing I
want to mention is a work by vishesh and
Salil from yet last year where they have
a theoretical result on univariate
gaussians and I was talking to miss Shan
I think they have they've done some
working towards making these things
actually realizable going say beyond the
theory which I think I'm interested in
hearing more about in terms of other
univariate problems with studied there's
been also work on you know very discrete
distribution say learning them in Colmar
of distance and also a total variation
distance including some work on
structure distributions in a total
variation distance but the real question
here is what about high dimensional data
can we do anything meaningful for high
dimensional distribution estimation
problems so I'm going to tell you what
our results are and I'm going to present
it sort of piece by piece because it's a
kind of a big statement and can be a bit
scary but be brave and I'll walk you
through it so we're going to I'm gonna
show you that there exists a private
algorithm which learns the Gaussian that
is we're going to be given data which is
drawn according to some Gaussian
distribution it's going to be D
dimensional and has some parameters mu
and Sigma this is going to be sort of
the quantification in terms of how our
of our uncertainty in the sense that
we're going to be given some upper bound
on the norm of the mean and also some
bounds on how the covariance looks it
just sort of to focus on the first term
the idea is this is similar how how big
a ball can how small a ball rather can
we draw around the true mean and be sort
of guaranteed that our mean will
actually be within this ball so there's
kind of trying to capture the phenomenon
that I showed you a few slides ago and
this the second condition is kind of
similar except for covariance is the
natural way to do what I claim
and if you do this this is the setup and
this is the stay I'm sorry I should
mention one last thing we're going to
try to estimate the distribution in
terms of total variation distance
there's also known as the statistical
distance at one distance if you don't
like that you can also think of it as
some sort of parameter estimation
problem in the appropriate way kind of
like what Marko is asking in an
appropriate way which is appropriate for
galaxies yeah and then if you do this
then the sample complexity will be the
following term like I said it can be a
bit scary but let me try to walk you
through the terms which are relevant so
if you take a look at the first term
this is actually the non-private sample
complexity of this problem that is d
squared over alpha squared I'll note if
you look at the four terms there's
nothing which is really super quadratic
in the dimension we're going to have a
second term which is kind of if you look
at if you paid attention to the
Bernoulli thing in the last slide you'll
notice that it's this kind of the same
thing you know we have d squared over
alpha squared it's natural to expect a d
squared over Alpha Epsilon
in fact it's also required but the main
thing I guess going back to the story I
told you before we have a mild
dependence on these uncertainty
parameters R and Kappa in the following
sense recall that you know we had a t
over epsilon in the we sort of had an
uncertainty of a T in the example but we
could reduce that to say log of a T we
have some lower bound showing that some
sort of these some of these dependences
are necessary for example like the
second term is tight and we need at
least a logarithmic dependence in this
type of model and we also have similar
results for product distributions which
I'm not going to talk about today ok so
before I continue is there any questions
about the statement itself the theorem
or how it maps to what we discussed
before
there is a bomb Kappa on that you don't
know Cal passenger like probably no
matter what did you do some kind of
public search and make tests whether
like a cap of pre algorithm in some
sense uh that that's a good question
like I like I said there you sort of
have to pay there is a lower bound based
on that term you can't really deal with
the case where it's uh well let me
revise that I'd have to think about a
bit more but my immediate impression is
no but I see what you're saying yeah any
other questions thanks for purity P you
need a dependable yes an R and then
probably is true also for concentrated
there's probably in DNA sample
complexity may have a dependence on
capital but you may be no need to know
Kappa ahead of time you just at the
point when you like are done you will
have used like log of capital many
samples but you don't need to like start
knowing what it is does that make sense
in the privacy definition of whether
what it makes us yeah it's a good it's a
good subtlety which I think I'd have to
think about when I'm not at the podium
cuz Mac you've dropped thirty points at
that audience if you want to think of
any terms of the distance in parameters
this will in this I guess will will mean
that you must be close to like the right
mean in some way that depends on the
covariance correct yeah it sort of in
like the Mahalanobis distance which is
sort of like rescaled by the covariance
I'll show you exactly what I mean at
least with the covariance case which I'm
gonna focus on today because I think
that's more technically interesting but
yeah one sort of thing related also to
the sort of discussion about whether or
not this is required let me know in the
peer and approximate oh sorry pure in
concentrated cases we know that we have
a log dependence for the high
dimensional problem it's current
good question whether you can get
completely Kappa free in the
one-dimensional case in fish and sileo's
paper they do get rid of it either way
this is getting a bit into the details
for Raleigh the audience so I'm gonna
continue any other questions like that
yeah case you go from G Square to D so
is there a way to get the results that
kind of like smoothly interpolate
between these two cells so let me
imagine there's a binary product
distributions is not for gaussians that
said there is a good question or there's
also the question if you just want to do
mean estimation of a Gaussian if you
know the covariance is kind of like also
D if you don't know the covariance and
actually the best algorithm we know if
the data this we have this is a kind of
an interesting phenomenon I'll be happy
to talk about more offline though cool
and in today's talk I'm actually going
to focus on a simpler version of this
problem that is the case where the mean
is zero and talk about how to do
covariance estimation because I think
that's kind of where some of the neat
techniques come in in the high
dimensional case let me note that if we
so if Kappa if capital were small that
is sort of we had a very good estimate
already for the covariances then this
problem would be very easy as I'll show
you in a few slides I'll tell you a very
simple algorithm for it but the
challenge is sort of when our
uncertainty is very like it is very
large and we give a private recursive
method to reduce the condition number
okay so the question is what is learning
a multivariate Gaussian there's a
question of learning and TV versus
learning in parameter distance I'm going
to flash some sort of scary-looking
equation on the on that side of the
board and then I'll show you a nice
picture which is usually how I like to
think about it so we're gonna be given
samples from some Gaussian like this and
we want to output a covariance order for
proxy for the covariance with the
following property we want it to be
close to the original the true
covariance and this funny norm up to
alpha and this funny norm is sort of
equivalent is that's kind of the
rescaled version of the Frobenius norm
you can stare at this if you want if
that makes
great and this will give you low total
variation distance but perhaps the more
intuitive way of thinking about it is
often we picture covariance matrices the
sort of ellipsoid so you can see this
red one is the true ellipsoid the true
covariance but we're going to have
something which is approximately it and
you'll note that this sort of like
relative it's a multiplicative
approximation than kind of all
directions in the sense you see this
thin direction it's going to be a fairly
close approximation but if we have a bit
more leeway in the long directions sort
of like I'm also picking a factor in all
directions of what we want okay so let's
start by talking about how we would non
privately learn a Gaussian in the
setting so we're given a data set x1
through xn from this distribution and I
think we all know the or it's it's known
that you can output the empirical
covariance and this will be a good
estimate in particular the accuracy
you're going to get is something like
this so in particular if you set to end
to be d squared over alpha squared you
can get the total variation guarantee
that I mentioned before and the question
is how to privatise well of course like
we sort of discussed before maybe the
Gaussian mechanism would be a nice thing
to try I'm going to give you a quick
recap of the Galaxy mechanism I guess
this should be pretty familiar for most
of you so let me just state it first for
the univariate setting we're going to
you know look at the sensitivity of the
statistic yeah this would probably be no
yours many of you so over a bit faster
but the idea is we're going to take the
non-private statistic we're going to add
Gaussian noise proportional with the
standard deviation proportional to the
sensitivity over epsilon and then output
that and it can be shown that this is a
epsilon this is appropriately private
and the one thing maybe which you have
to think about for a second the fact is
how accurate is this
well I claim just you to like Gaussian
tale bounds this is sort of going to be
within a constant number of standard
deviations so the accuracy will be
something like this in fact be like
about sensitivity over epsilon okay but
we're dealing with high dimensional
problems so in fact we're going to raise
everything to we'll look at D by D
covariance matrices and in particular
this is just going to be the following
uh there's gonna be the same sort of
natural generalization the idea is
you're going to add get independent
Gaussian noise to each entry of the
covariance matrix and that's the
Gaussian mechanism it'll be
appropriately private and give you this
type of error guarantee accuracy
guarantee if you're familiar with the
paper analyze gauss bide work at all
this is kind of like the the main
algorithm they have in their thing but
ok so this is a first method that we're
going to look at let's try private
covariance estimation and we're having
some data set we're going to put now the
empirical covariance matrix but with you
know Gaussian noise added to each entry
the accuracy guarantee we're going to
get as the following the issue is what
is the sensitivity of the statistic if
you remember the example at the
beginning we're going to run into very
similar issues in the following sense we
imagine that you know our data set looks
so it should look something nice like
this you know it's a nice Gaussian sort
of near the me near zero but the issue
is that this is an actually in this
setting the empirical covariance is
rather sensitive for example you could
have one point which is placed out here
and this would cause the empirical
covariance to shift from something maybe
more like that to something like this
I'm being a bit yes yes it will be a
symmetric that's that's very like if you
want to the you you the actual algorithm
will be adding it's a to the upper
triangular part upper triangular part
and then uh you know mirroring it with
the exact same noise
so yeah you can see that this is a
rather sensitive statistic a priori
because you know one data point could go
anywhere and this could arbitrarily
shift the covariance matrix empirically
so in other words we've got an N equals
Owen's of infinity sample algorithm
which is not great machine precision one
but no we'll skip that but the idea is
we can use a very similar idea first in
order to do something similar to what we
did in the height example I gave at the
beginning the idea is we're going to
limit the sensitivity of this via
truncation now what we know is we have
two bounds
we know that the covariance is greater
than the identity so nothing lies within
this inner circle and also the
covariance is upper bounded by Kappa
times the identity so nothing lies
outside the outer circle and therefore
sort of the worst case for how much we
can shift the covariances bounded by how
much this this guy will pull our
covariance matrix this is the main idea
and we're going to sort of add it to our
algorithm before to sort of take into
account like I mentioned this kind of
going to be a you know a rescaled
version of analyze Gauss and I'm going
to mention called the truncating than
empirical method for a reason that'll be
clear later or I guess when I tell you
it'll be pretty evident why this is
truncated empirical we're going to first
truncate by removing every point which
is too large that is take me at faith
when I say that if the data actually
came from a Gaussian which has these
properties then this step will
essentially do nothing there's not
useful for the stochastic guarantee but
would this will be useful for for the
like worst case data privacy because now
we are limiting the sensitivity and this
will in fact bound Delta to be ho tilde
of Kappa times the dimension so now
we're going to given this sort of a
winds arise data set or either winds
arise truncated whatever you like then
we will have this statistic where you
compute the empirical covariance and
then you add Gaussian noise of the
appropriate magnitude
each entry of the covariance as I sort
of mentioned before this will give you
accuracy which has this sort of
guarantee here and if you sort of invert
this to see what sort of total variation
guarantee this gives you this tells you
that if you want to estimate up to alpha
total variation you have the following
sample complexity so let's let's distill
this and see what we have so far I'm
claiming there exists a private
algorithm which learned the Gaussian in
total variation distance with this
sample complexity you'll note that this
is actually pretty close to what we want
except for this pesky factor of Kappa
right here if capital was oh if 1 then
we would be done and we could call it a
day
the issue is sort of due to this type of
uncertainty that I mentioned Kappa could
be very large so any question about the
statement before I continue why this is
a good baseline but not great when we
have a lot of uncertainty you inverting
Sigma hat or the original Sigma's so
this is sort of like a worst case for
anything in that so kind of I think the
worst case would be if it actually is
the identity and so yeah this is like
exactly then it would give you no
totally cool so let's try to see what
exactly went wrong with this algorithm
what would really where did we lose here
and the idea is as follows suppose we
had a lot of samples that is bigger than
Kappa times the dimensions squared then
our noise would be small in a sense the
right ellipsoid is the empirical co-vary
the true covariance and then our noise
will be somehow small if we add it on
you can see we get the sort of guarantee
that I mentioned in the sense it's
closed in every direction up to this
about
in other words if we have a lot of data
our noised empirical covariance will be
close to the true covariance the issue
is if this condition here does not hold
in the sense that if n is smaller than
Kappa times dimensions squared then
it'll look something a bit more like
this
where if you add it you get you get this
sort of rather more more spherical
looking covariance here in other words
if you take a careful look at this
you'll note that we have a noise
empirical covariance which is pretty
good estimation in the long directions
but somehow in the short directions we
don't have as good an estimate so our
goal for algorithmically will be to try
to discover and add less noise in these
short directions in order to in order to
like refine our estimate and get
something better okay and yeah like I
said the noise a greater signal in the
small directions so our goal will be to
approximately learn Sigma in all
directions and the key like algorithmic
primitive which we'll have to do to do
this sort of how we would formalize this
is by saying there exists a private
algorithm which finds a matrix a hat
which we'll call a pre-conditioner and
the idea is if you sort of rescale the
covariance by this a pre-conditioner
that'll put it in approximately
isotropic form up to a factor of say a
hundred or some constant factor and the
sample complexity of this will be d to
the three-halves loged square root log
of cap over epsilon and you'll notice
this with one of the terms in our sample
complexity before and suppose we had
this algorithm I'm just going to state
this in fact I'm not going to get into
the details in this talk but suppose we
had this algorithm this is how we would
use it the idea is we start sort of in
the regular domain this is the problem
now we're going to first learn a
pre-conditioner which will try to make
it more spherical and try to say that's
between the identity and a constant
times the identity what we're going to
do then is learn the the distribution
learn the covariance in the sort of
transform space and then by an
appropriate rescaling we shift back to
the original space
and pretty much the next slide which
will be about my last technical slide
will sort of formalize this we're given
some data set we're going to first learn
this pre-conditioner that I mentioned in
order to put it in roughly isotropic
form we're going to do the truncate and
empirical method the thing I presented
in a few slides ago on the data set but
now we're going to precondition it by
multiplying by this sort of
transformation matrix and then we're
going to output the covariance which is
sort of rescaling back to the original
domain this is sort of what I showed you
in a few pictures in the previous slide
so step one the the first step to learn
is pre-conditioner is going to be the
sample complexity and the second step
now you'll notice that remember I told
you this is the sample complexity Kappa
times d squared over Alpha Epsilon but
because now we have this condition we
have it sort of appropriately
conditioned then this will just be the
right sample complexity so we can check
that off the one thing you might be
wondering is how exactly do we do step
one I'm not going to talk about that in
this talk so let me hardly click through
but okay basically just to sort of
conclude we have this algorithm which
learned the Gaussian with these sort of
sim with these the sample complexity we
give the first algorithm for privately
learning gaussians and product
distributions at high dimensions and
it's the first one with mild dependence
on these uncertainty parameters and
showing that privacy comes that sort of
a small cost in these settings thank you
[Applause]
so the preconditioning is sort of like
principle something like this you're
basically trying to downscale those
later dimensions yeah yeah the idea is
to try to find which which direction
they're long which directions are short
the question is how to sort of do this
without taking d squared samples and
paying a lot yeah I think I think this
is like it's likely possible that we
could sort of relax the assumptions a
bit in the sense that we just have you
know since it's a Gaussian we'll have
certain types of concentration it's
likely possible that you can as long as
any distribution which satisfies that
type of requirement you could also run
it on there's something which I think
some of us are thinking a little bit
more about but hasn't been sort of had
the top priority
point points which are very far away yes
wins right sure sure so the thing is
actually in in it if the data actually
came from a Gaussian this would actually
make no difference at all in the sense
that I truncated or removed points which
are which they wouldn't actually be
sampled ever except with like very very
small probabilities so in terms of the
statistical accuracy that should not
make a difference except in terms of the
noise you add perhaps if you want to
make this more practical it might
actually be reasonable to be more more
judicious in terms of how you truncate
and clip things and then you would be
able to add less noise at the cost of
maybe losing some of your data yeah in
terms of whether to truncate verses clip
or winds rise this is all this is sort
of they're all roughly equivalent in my
mind from a theoretical standpoint
okay
good time I don't want to go over I'm
just I'm mr. akyüz about the lower bound
M of I because for most data analysis we
need sort of high dimensional context
usually you feel like there's some major
directions which are important and then
you would get easier
noisy directions so it seems the sort of
lower bound of that entity seems that
unnatural to me but maybe this there's
rescaling which makes it clear yeah
that's fair I think there's some things
you can do like you think some Direction
might be degenerate say or I mean sort
of the motivation of principal
components yeah yeah that's the key
structure and everything else yeah I
know in say approximate DP it's possible
to even like get rid of the low I
believe it's possible to get rid of the
dimensions which are which are
degenerate in that sense because the
metric you're using just total variation
I mean this is just to send too
sensitive to having these it's plausible
I would have to think about a bit more
but yeah it's kind of like because if
you get anything wrong in sort of a flat
direction that's automatically total
variation this is what right so it's
probably it's plausibly because of that
the question is perhaps what's a better
way to estimate what a better
yeah maybe you make sense this allele
since the dependence on this kind of
ratio between the upper bound and lower
bound the covariance is only logarithmic
at least in theory you could you could
use like as your lower about not I but
some really really tiny multiple of x
and really only if it's like zero in
some directions you would you run for
trouble okay but usually I mean but
usually those those small eigen values
are running to zero quite the please
that dimension growth right all I know
meal okay right but this law gives like
the number of bits of precision there
which the in theory is okay in practice
probably it's not all right I suggest
that we